the division is the hot anything out
right now and if you're anything like me
you're itching to play it pretty much
constantly
fortunately plenty of you do seem to be
exploring post-apocalyptic New York and
finding a bunch of cool Easter eggs in
the process here are five of my
favorites
first off there is a massive
adventuretime mural to be found in an
early area of the game buried within
what appears to be a sort of children's
playground in Pennsylvania Plaza are two
massive walls featuring Adventure Time
inspired art of course given actual
Adventure Time characters and assets are
copyrighted you'll need to use a little
bit of your imagination but you should
be able to appreciate the distinctly
similar art style of murals which
beaches all the gaping smiles critters
rainbows mountains and backpacks and
that you've come to expect some clever
reddit users uncovered an easter egg
referencing yet another cult favorite
animated series on the corner of 31st
and 7th Street ikan spot eight pizza box
lying in the snow with a pair of
nunchucks lying on top of it if you
still haven't gotten on the reference
there is two the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles given Michelangelo wielded that
very weapon and like his brothers also
happen to be super into pizza the pizza
box also reads radical likely a
reference to Raphael commonly uttered
phrase of approval if you need even more
reasons to stop and smell the post
apocalypse in the decision there is an
awesome secret to be found at references
shaun of the dead in a back alley in
chelsea every so often in the division
you'll run into an echo these are
basically moody Holograms have generally
gloomy things that happen to people
standing right where you are from a
while back this example is not so gloomy
if you like me have seen shaun of the
dead more times than you have fingers
you'll appreciate this reference to the
hilarious fence scene where Shaun
reckons he's a bit more athletic than he
is
next up if you want the ships get out of
you you can check out a haunted pharmacy
if you near the pharmacies entrance
you'll hear a woman singing and hushing
a child there are also several
televisions covered in static although
and a certain point something seems to
appear on one of them if you dare to
venture further in you can hear the
sound of a child calling for its mother
even though you don't come across any
actual corporeal people there is a blink
and you'll miss it ghostly figure in a
doorway inside if you thought the
post-apocalypse couldn't get any scarier
you
for Rome generally Easter eggs tend to
be references to films TV shows or games
but this one happens to be a reference
to the whole of Ubisoft located in
Turtle Bay past the dark zone you can
find a safe house called the firewall
between East 34th Street and 2nd Avenue
which should feature a lot of familiar
things
that's all Ubisoft a dev studio features
a massive Ubisoft banner loads of grow
home art and a full honor poster there's
also a whiteboard that reads submission
deadline November last push peek
these are just a small selection of what
is surely a ton of good Easter eggs and
secrets buried in the divisions
Manhattan so be sure to let me know what
cool ones you come across our faces